بالعوده الى خبر مرسوم الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتن لحظر توليد النفط والمنتجات
النفطيه لدول التي فرضت سقفا على الاسعار
خلط الاوراق هذا القرار مجددا في سوق
الطاقه العالميه ويدخل القرار حيز التنفيذ
في الاول من فبراير شباط 2000 و 2023
ويستمر لمده خمسه اشهر تذكر بالدول
المعنيه بقرار حضرتك وهي دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي التي تبلغ صادرات روسيا النفطيه
اليها نحو خمسه واربعين في المئه كما يظهر
مجموعه الدول السبعه الكبرى التي تضم
الولايات المتحده بريطانيا فرنسا وايضا
المانيا وايطاليا وكندا واليابان من
الموافقين على وضعه حد اقصى لسعر النفط
الروسي المنقول بحرا عند 60 دولارا
للبرميل تصدر روسيا 10% من منتجاتها
النفسيه الى سوق الامريكيه
مش راضيه ايضا من المنضمين الى حلف تحديد
سقف لاسعار الطاقه وتعتمد بدرجه اقل على
واردات الطاقه من روسيا 90% من شحنات
النفط العالميه يجري تامينها من قبل شركات
في مجموعه الدول السبع ما يعني ان نقل
النفط الروسي خارج خصوم موسكو سيكون معقدا
جدا ذكرت وكاله بنومبرج الامريكيه
النواتير تتحول صادرات روسيا من النفط
الخام الى اسيا تزايدت في الاشهر الاخيره
ابدا يتجه ثلثاء نفط الخام منقول عبر
ناقلات في موانع الروسيه الان الى اسيا
بينما كانت النسبه تقل عن 50% قبل اندلاع
حرب روسيا في اوكرانيا من شان القدره
الاسيويه على امتصاص نحو نصف حجم صادرات
الخام الروسي المنقوله بحرا وهي 500 1,000
برميل يوميا تضاف الى مليوني برميل وهي
حجم الصادرات النفطيه اليوميه الاساسيه
تتجه الانظار الى مسافه تكرير الصينيه
التي سجلت نشاطا ملحوظا في الاونه الاخيره
فيما اعلنت الهند انها ستواصل شراء مشتقات
النفط الروسيه شكلت صادرات النفط الروسيه
22% من اجمالي واردات الهند من الخام
مسجله
946,000 برميل يوميا خلال شهر اكتوبر
الماضي ينضم الينا من لندن الخبير في شؤون
الطاقه مصطفى البازركان اهلا بك سيد مصطفى
سيد مصطفى كيف يمكن ان يؤثر القرار الروسي
على اسعار النفط وسوق النفط
طبعا اسعار النفط احتوت هذا القرار ولذلك
لم يكن القرار يعني يصل الى درجه مهمه
لماذا لان القرار اتخذ تم اتخاذه مسبقا من
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي والدوله السبع كما
ذكرتم في تقريركم و الفارق انه هو ثلاثه
ايام الرابع من شباط سيكون هناك ايقاف
لاستيراد مشتقات النفط الروسي والرئيس
بوتين همم قرر انه الاول من الشباب هذه
نقطه النقطه الثانيه لابد من ذكرها وهي
انه هناك تراجع يعني قبل اربعه ايام او
خمسه ايام كان هناك تصريح لوزير الطاقه
الروسي لوح انه روسيا قد تخفض انتاجها
بخمسه الى سبعه بالمئه من انتاجها الذي
يتجاوز 10 مليون البرلم يحصل وكان قرار
المرسوم لماذا انا براي شخص انه لم يكون
هناك موافقه من دول المنتجه للنفط خاصه
اوبك بلس التي همم يعني
اوكي تحالف مع روسيا لماذا لم هذا
الخبر يعني يقول بانه لم يتشاور مع اوبك
بلس
صحيح لم يتشاور ولكن بالتاكيد يعرف الراي
ال- ال- ال- ال-
الجانب الاخر ولذلك تراجع عن هذا القرار
وكان القرار بهذا المرسوم هذا المرسوم همم
فيه ثلاثه نقاط مهمه اولا همم عمليه تحويل
همم الاسواق وايجاد اسواق بديله همم روسيا
منذ اشهر بدات تسترجع ناقلات النفط من
ايران ومن فنزويلا وهي بحدود الاكثر من
100 ناقله نفط كانت تستخدمها ايران
للالتفاف على العقوبات وكذلك فنزويلا
وبدات تستخدمها من اجل ايجاد اسواق بديله
في جنوب شرق اسيا هذه نقطه النقطه الثانيه
حينما يقول الرئيس بوتن انه هذا المرسوم
لديه امكانيه في عدم شمول دوله او عده دول
بهذا القرار وهو يقصد في شك وحده الاتحاد
الاوروبي لماذا لان هناك دول تلفظ هذا
القرار على سبيل المثال النقطه الثالثه
والاهم حينما يحدد خمس اشهر خمسه اشهر
بمعنى ينتظر اجتماع الصيفي لمنظمه اوبك
بلس طيب يعني موافقه تقديراتك مع وجود
اسواق جديد تتوجه اليها روسيا هل ستتاثر
عائدات روسيا من النفط بهذا القرار
بالتاكيد تراجع السعر يعني روسيا اليوم
مدخولها في شهر نوفمبر من مبيعات النفط
شهريا 20 مليار دولار مع تراجع النفط لا
ننسى انه كما ذكرتهم في تقرير
المتميز انه الصين همم الهند تستورد لنفط
الروسي بخفض 35 دولار من البرميل الصين
كذلك حتى الغاز تحصل على 25% خفض سيكون
هناك خفض اضافي بالتاكيد لماذا هو مساله
العرض والطلب في تراجع مدخول روسيا من
النفط ولكن هل ذلك سيؤثر على اسعار النفط
العالميه انا اشكرك الاسعار في اسعار
النفط سيد مصطفى الاسعار بالنسبه للهند
والصين ولكن هنالك ازدياد في الكميات هذه
الزياده في الكميات لا تعادل النقص في
الاسعار او الحسم الذي تقدمه روسيا لكل من
الهند والصين
صحيح ولكن لا ننسى انه الهند والصين هناك
شركات تستثمر في ذلك النفط الخام الصين
الهندي حد هذا اليوم تستورد النفط الروسي
بتخفيض وتعيد تكريرها وتبيع اكثر من مليون
برميل من منتجات النفط المكرره الى شركات
في دول الاتحاد الاوروبي فهذا معناه تحصل
على نفط مخفض ولكن انه تبيعه بالاسعار
العالميه هذا سياتي تحت طائله همم
اسعار النفط الروسي مصطفى
الخبير في شؤون الطاقه